[Musique]
bonsoir à nous sommes le mardi 27
septembre merci de nous rejoindre pour
ce nouveau numéro du 7 8 le débat votre
rendez vous chaque mardi sur un thème de
société ou politique la décision du
préfet dé il est tombé ce vendredi un
plan d'accueil pour 400 migrants est
prévue sur le territoire les sites de
l'inria arguant pour et de ville vers al
hussein sont directement concernés et
l'arrivée de ces personnes est imminente
du côté des mères et de l'agglomération
de versailles grand parc l'inquiétude
grandit une partie de la population
gronde également et malgré tout la
france s'engage elle promet d'héberger
ces populations dans le besoin alors
faut-il accueillir des migrants en
divine c'est le sujet de ce débat en
plateau avec moi pour en débattre
valérie d'aubigny conseillère municipale
de versailles familles à venir dont sort
à vous merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous avez dernièrement
manifester c'était samedi dernier contre
ce projet d'installation notamment à
louveciennes vous êtes donc contre et
face à vous pierre déjean président de
la fédération des villes de la ligue des
droits de l'homme vous avez vous même
récemment publié un communiqué de presse
pour affirmer votre position en faveur
de l'accueil de ces personnes mars
également de nous avoir rejoints alors
j'aimerais commencer avec vous à valérie
de bini pourquoi vous avez manifesté
contre ce projet samedi 27 ans pourquoi
êtes vous content vous pouvez vous nous
expliquer pourquoi avons-nous manifester
et bien parce que la nouvelle est
arrivée de manière très indirecte par
des fuites dans la presse donc elle a
d'abord été qualifié de rumeurs etc vous
imaginez dans la population le l'émoi
que cela cela a pu engendrer parce qu'il
ne s'agit pas d'une petite décision
c'est une décision lourde qui semble
très arbitraire à la population et qui
donc spontanément et très rapidement a
eu envie de se rassembler et de et de et
de crier je dirais son son besoin
d'avoir de l'information et de dire non
on ne nous impose pas comme cela une
décision si grave et si lourde de
conséquences pour la population donc oui
samedi c'était effectivement à un
rassemblement citoyen spontané
pour dire non et pour pour dire cette
colère car des gens les yvelines doivent
accueillir des migrants 400 personnes
sont prévues pour les territoires
d'abord joué peut-être préciser un point
c'est que la question qui se pose alors
aussi bien pauline et que pour d'autres
départements ce n'est pas faute et là
qu'il ya les migrants
c'est une obligation c'est une
obligation légale de par les textes qu'à
voter et ratifie et des beautés de la
france est ratifié par le parlement ne
serait-ce que en 48 la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme en 51
la convention de genève en 67 si je ne
m'abuse le protocole de new york qui
fait obligation à tous les états
signataires de ce texte d'accueillir
effectivement tous les réfugiés toutes
les personnes qui sont persécutés pour
une raison ou pour une autre donc c'est
une obligation a pas basses aux mines
mais pourquoi pas il n'y a aucune raison
de refuser pour les élus ce qui serait
obligatoire pour les autres départements
ces textes oui effectivement mais il
faut voir le contexte actuel nous sommes
vraiment face à une vague migratoire
c'est cela qui s'opère nous ne sommes
pas la face à des personnes qui sont
toutes des réfugiés qui demandent
l'asile parce que chez elles si elles y
restent elles zimmer ce n'est pas le cas
il se trouve que dans les yvelines
précisément on accueille depuis déjà de
nombreuses années des personnes qui sont
dans cette situation là et on les
accueille bien on les accueille bien
parce que ça se passe de personne à
personne de petites structures à petites
structures paroisses communes etc et les
yvelinois de ce côté là ne manque pas de
générosité mais à l'heure actuelle il
s'agit de replacer des personnes qui
sont là et qu'il faut
dont il faut discerner bien le statut
de quoi vous avez vous avez peur vous
dites on ne sait pas exactement d'où à
ces personnes viennent pourquoi
sacrifier des frais ce ne sont pas
toutes des réfugiés par la valeur mais
écoutez je pense qu'il suffit de
regarder ce qu'il se passe partout et
notamment regarder la population qui se
trouve à calais aujourd'hui
vous savez que là on examine les
situations de ces personnes il y à des
magistrats des personnes qui regardent
leurs dossiers et si vous les interrogez
vous vous rendez compte que l elles leur
font raconter leurs histoires leurs
histoires personnelles et elles savent
très bien que les passeurs qui les ont
amenés là leur part en leur demandant
des sommes d'ailleurs très importante
c'est un vrai trafic en même temps qu'il
leur vendent le passage ils le revendent
le mensonge est très souvent je ne fais
pas une généralité mais je dis qu'il
faut discerner dans ces populations est
très souvent le mensonge est le même
selon les provenances et c'est donc
vraiment il ya un discernement à opérer
et notre pays dans la situation actuelle
il se trouve aujourd'hui ne peut plus se
permettre aveuglément de d'ouvrir les
bras à cette vague migratoire
il s'agit le plus souvent d'immigrés
illégaux d'immigrés économique et non de
réfugiés
c'est une affirmation tout à fait
gratuite
si j'étais méchant mais je ne suis pas
soit je redis maintenant songer en tout
cas
le statut de réfugié c'est pas en fait
quelqu'un arrive par principe il est
réfugié valent quand il le quand il le
dit comme ça à calais enfin 5 500
migrants
réfugiés quand on est réfugié comme
quentin migrants pardon parce que l'on
fuit la guerre parce qu'on fait une
persécution que de quelconques soient
politiques qu'elles soient
sexuelles qu'elles soient religieuses
quelque peu importe la raison quand on
habite et une persécution on va dans
notre prix on demande effectivement
refuge et 7 ce refuge il est de droit ce
qui veut pas dire qu'effectivement
c'est une session une situation qui peut
perdurer il est de droit parce que la
personne ne demande ensuite on examine
son cas pour voir effectivement la
réalité de ces persécutions mais quand
il arrive évidemment il faut s'en
occuper
sur sur calais effectivement il ya doit
avoir cette huile personnes actuellement
ce sont peut dire à 90 ou 95% des
réfugiés mais pour pour revenir plus
proche de nous dans les yvelines l'aga
khan 800 personnes qui se sont
mobilisées samedi justement vous
comprenez voilà que c'est un fait
inquiète j'ai je comprends tout à fait
la mobilisation sauf que contrairement à
ce que dit madame c'est pas le monde une
manifestation spontanée elle été
sciemment organisé par votre groupe
d'ailleurs qui s'est déjà manifestée par
ses positions
xénophobes je dirais même une gestion et
je dis vraiment c'est je dirais même
raciste attention vous savez que nous ne
laissons pas passer les modes les mots
diffamants et bien et bien et bien
écoutez ne laissez pas passer
moi même je ne les laisse pas passer
quand lorsque vous avez publié votre
lettre au mois de mars à propos de la
pana j'ai tout de suite consulté le
service juridique de la ligue qui m'a
dit willy affectivement matière de
discrimination on n'a pas pas question
technique mais effectivement votre
lettre était tout à fait
condamnable du centre des débats la
question c'est accueillir les migrants
dans les yvelines c'est un peu la même
chose parce que là le la pad à la
plateforme d'admission des demandeurs
d'asile
nom l'indiqué est destiné aux demandes
d'asile donc ce sont des gens qui
viennent là qui sont persécutés et qui
demandent l'asile alors si vous le
permettez effectivement elle se modifie
ce mot de discriminatoire et venant de
votre association en reprise par le
préfet au moment où nous nous sommes
déjà opposé à l'installation de la
plateforme d'accueil de demandeurs
d'asile souvenez vous c'était il ya
quelques mois aux portes du chesnay et
de versailles devant le plus gros groupe
scolaire de versailles en tant qu'élu ne
nous sommes émus de cette situation de
ce choix absolument
irresponsable et cela n'avait rien de
discriminatoire et là je pense que le
mot est tout à fait abusif je pense que
vous allez avoir recentré alors reçu à
trop nous recentrons un petit peu la
tension ou nouvelle mais que vous avez
écrit on n'est pas là pour régler réaux
contre débattre de vos furets
c'est écrit jacques pecquery moi ce que
je veux dire c'est que là vous venez
tout à l'heure de
qualifier mes propos de mensongers
effectivement s'il s'agissait de réfugié
politique de réfugiés parce que s'ils
restent dans leur pays comme je disais
tout à l'heure et zimmer je pense que
ces hommes seuls entre 25 et 35 ans ne
partirai pas seul il partirait avec leur
famille ça c'est quand même une chose
est déjà la risée le vieux moine ce sont
les hommes seuls qui arrive justement à
venir par exemple en france et leurs
familles dont les femmes et les enfants
malheureusement parfois n'y arrive pas
certes mais enfin écoutez moi si je
savais tout ma famille en danger si
j'étais un homme je ne partirai pas seul
je ne laisserai pas ma mère mais ma
femme ma femme mes soeurs n'ont
véritablement moi même si j'étais en
danger jed et fils et un mari je ne leur
dirai pas à lévis et
nous restons là il ya quelque chose tout
de même dans les faits qui est sincère
servian voilà le territoire des yvelines
l'argent a dit tous les territoires
français vont assurément pourquoi le
territoire des yvelines ne peut pas en
accueillir oui alors là sur ce point si
vous me permettez de dire que nous ne
sommes pas du tout en train de défendre
un trait carré en criant essoufflant
très fort pour que ça parte plus loin
pas du tout nous vraiment nous voulons
nous battre contre cette vague
migratoire général et là où notre action
serait utile intéressante c'est de se
battre sur sur les causes et les causes
premières il faut bien trouver des
solutions
aujourd'hui alors jusqu'au
l'interruption solution est là dans un
futur très proche cette vague migratoire
qui arrive tout d'un coup elle n'existe
pas comme elle est elle est là des
migrants qui arrivent effectivement mais
ya pas de vagues si vous prenez les la
circulation des migrants la plupart des
migrants et cela se comprend tout à fait
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de se
déplacer eh bien ils vont le pays d'à
côté et dans les pays qui sont autour
des zones de guerre par exemple 6 par
million qu il gâte de jute d'aider des
gens déplacés ainsi que ce sont des âmes
en ciel dans ce biais de sondages c'est
bien une vague
et on sait désormais ce qu'ils viennent
ceux qui viennent bon ils ont subi un
certain nombre d'épreuves parce que
c'est pas facile de venir parce que
vous savez il n'ya pas d'aidé des
bateaux des trains ou des avions qui
sont affrétés comme ça pour libérer les
gens vous parlez sein de votre vue v u
de versailles est ce que j'espère
agréable pour vous mais si vous étiez
dans ce cas là bas c'est un peu le
système t1 vous pouvez alors accusé les
hommes de venir sans leur famille c'est
bien jolie madame donnez leur les moyens
d'emmener leurs familles alors donnons
leur les moyens de chez eux au début de
notre entretien nous parlions justement
de s'être de cet accueil qui se fait de
manière dosé de gens qui sont arrivés
qui sont chez nous actuellement et dont
d'ailleurs on n'entend pas parler parce
qu'ils ont été accueillis d'une manière
d'une manière naturelle dans des trucs
par petites structures
là il s'agit de caen énorme vous voyez
bien sombre ici en tout cas dans les
yvelines saison les il a dit 'on à 200
mais par exemple à l'ancienne c'est 100
personnes qui doivent être accueillis
aussi une progression de 7000 habitants
ces séances est ce que l'on nous dit à
lucian ses quatre hectares 1 le préfet
distille ses informations et distille
ses chiffres on sait très bien qu'une
fois que les choses seront entamés elles
ne pourront que grossir ça s'est passé
comme ça à calais on est aujourd'hui à
9000 et c'est ainsi que cela se passe
c'est que l'on roule à ce que l'on voit
aussi c'est que j'aurai par le préfet
ces populations répartis sur tout le
territoire pour ça je vais m'excuser je
n'avais pas tout à fait fini ma phrase
selon eux cela ne se passe bien nulle
part parce que c'est extrêmement
difficile de faire cette massification
de la calle bien ce n'est pas vrai ce
n'est pas vrai du tout des gens comme il
hier en tête est terminée il ya des
malades et à sa diète des communes qui
ont accepté l'immigrant qui ont fait ce
qu'il fallait pour en accueillir
quelques-uns et iman le problème qui se
pose à calais ou à paris parce que il ya
également un problème à paris c'est
effectivement la concentration qui a
sauté personnes dans des conditions de
vie épouvantables
et ça effectivement non seulement il
faut le résoudre mais c'est bien à
l'état de le résoudre ces deux sets ça
fait partie de ses prérogatives
donc maintenant il faut pas que les
maires ou les élus autres menaces ils
mettent des bâtons dans les roues bien
soigné des problèmes ce sera l'honneur
de nous de vendre l'antenne je suis
désolé on dort l'antenne cette émission
à s'achève merci à vous deux fin du set
8 le débat qui portait ce soir sur
l'accueil des migrants dans les yvelines
voilà nous avons deux arrêtés qui n'ont
pas réussi à se mettre d'accord comme à
chaque fois dans cette ville de l'eba
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet a commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux je souhaite une excellente
soirée richard voir
[Musique]